tengo aquí un grupo de expresiones
radicales raíces cuadradas resolveremos
y simplificaremos cada una de ellas y
analizaremos si el resultado es un
número racional o un número irracional
hagamos entonces el inciso a
nos piden encontrar la raíz cuadrada de
25 esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 5
por 5 y esto es claramente igual a 5
estamos hablando de la raíz cuadrada
positiva hagamos ahora el inciso b deja
de ponerlo con otro color raíz cuadrada
positiva o raíz cuadrada principal es la
que estamos encontrando inciso b nos
piden nos piden encontrar la raíz
cuadrada de 24 bien hagamos entonces la
factorización con números primos de 24
24 lo podemos escribir como 2 por 12 2
es 2 por 6
y seis es dos por tres y aquí ya tenemos
la factorización de 24 si es que 24 lo
puedo escribir como la raíz cuadrada de
dos por dos
por dos y por tres esto lo mismo que la
raíz cuadrada 24 y aquí tenemos un
cuadrado perfecto 2 por 2 es igual a 4
así es que esto es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 2 por 2 que multiplica a la
raíz cuadrada de dos por tres
ahora la raíz cuadrada 2 por 2 en la
raíz cuadrada 4 que es 2 eso ya lo
sabemos así es que esto es igual a 2 y
aquí no tenemos un número que se
multiplique a sí mismo por lo cual esto
es la raíz cuadrada de dos por tres la
raíz cuadrada de 6 también lo podríamos
escribir como la raíz cuadrada de 2 por
la raíz cuadra de 3 mencioné que íbamos
a analizar si los números sean
racionales irracionales 5 es un número
racional porque lo podemos escribir como
la razón de dos números 5 lo podemos
escribir como el cociente de 5 entre 1
es por eso que 5 es un número racional
en cambio 2 raíz de 6 este es un número
irracional no lo va a probar aquí pero
este es un número irracional pero
siempre que tengas
de dos números irracionales vas a
obtener un número racional
aquí tenemos raíz de 2 y raíz de 3 que
son irracionales no lo va a probar aquí
pero siempre que tienes la raíz cuadrada
de un número primo obtienes un número
irracional un número racional no lo
podemos escribir como un cociente de dos
números enteros es decir esto es
distinto de m / n donde m y n son
enteros a diferencia de 5 que lo podemos
escribir como 5 entre 1 ahora aquí raíz
de 24 podríamos haberla calculado
rápidamente como raíz de 4 por 6 sabemos
que la raíz de 4 es 2 entonces
tendríamos directamente el resultado 2
raíz de 6 pero bueno he querido proceder
de manera sistemática para ver cómo
tuvimos el resultado
hagamos inciso se inciso se la raíz
cuadrada de 20 la factorización en
primos es 2 por 10 y 10 lo puedo
escribir como 2 por 5
así es que esto es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de dos por dos
la raíz cuadrada de 5 y aquí tenemos la
raíz cuadrada de 2 por 2 que es
claramente 2 y raíz de 5 que está
multiplicando 2 raíz de 5 y de nueva
cuenta puedes haberlo hecho directamente
20 los factores como 4 por 5 y la
escuadra de 4 por la escuadra 5 2 raíz
de 5 hagamos ahora el inciso de el
inciso de tenemos que calcular la raíz
cuadrada de 200 el mismo procedimiento
la factorización de números primos de
200 esto es 2% tienes 2 por 50 52 por 25
y 25 es 5 por 5 así esquerra disco de
200 lo podemos escribir como déjame
moverme un poco hacia la derecha esto es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 2 por 2 2
por 2 por 2 por 5 y por 5 y esto aquí
tenemos un cuadro perfecto aquí tenemos
otro cuadro perfecto vamos a hacer todo
el proceso vamos a reescribir esto como
la raíz cuadrada de 2 por 2 que
multiplica a la raíz cuadrada de 2 que
multiplica a la raíz cuadrada de 5 x 5
raíz cuadrada de 2 x 2 raíz cuadrada 4
es 2 que multiplica la raíz cuadrada de
2 y la raíz cuadra de 5 por 5 en la raíz
quade 25 que es 5 reordenando términos
hago el producto de 2 por 5 y esto me
queda finalmente 10 raíz de 2 de nueva
cuenta este es un número irracional pues
este número no se puede escribir con una
razón de dos números m y n donde m y n
son enteros otra manera de ver esto es
que si tú escribes este número como un
número decimal los decimales se
presentan indefinidamente sin repetirse
hagamos el inciso e inciso e raíz
cuadrada de dos mil voy a hacerla acá
abajo inciso e raíz cuadrada de dos mil
de nueva cuenta la factorización por
números primos que hemos venido haciendo
2000 lo puedo escribir como 2
por mil
me lo puedo escribir como dos por
quinientos 500 es 2 por 250 252 por 125
125 es 5 por 25 y 25 es un poquito más
abajo 25 es 5 por 5
así es que raíz cuadrada de 2000 lo
puedo escribir como la raíz cuadrada y
voy a agrupar por cuadros perfectos esto
es 2 por dos uso paréntesis que
multiplica a dos por dos
que multiplica a cinco por cinco
multiplica cinco por cinco y sabemos
tenemos cuatro 12 y 35 y esto que
multiplica a 5 y ahora que tenemos bien
aquí observamos que aquí tenemos 2 por 2
que es 4
aquí tenemos 4 y aquí en una cuenta se
repite 4 así es que tenemos podemos
describir lo de arriba como la raíz
cuadrada de cuatro por cuatro que
multiplica a la raíz cuadrada de 5 por 5
y que multiplica a la raíz cuadrada de 5
la raíz 4x4 es obviamente 4 la raíz
cuadrada cinco por cinco en cinco y este
término que es raíz de cinco cuatro por
cinco es 20 20 que multiplica a raíz de
5 y de nueva cuenta este número es un
número irracional es un número
irracional vayamos al siguiente
ejercicio hagamos el insee 717 la raíz
cuadrada de un
inciso f la raíz cuadrada de un cuarto
hagamos entonces inciso f raíz cuadrada
de un cuarto la raíz cuadrada un cuarto
la puedo escribir como la raíz cuadrada
de 1 entre la raíz cuadrada de 4 la raíz
cuadrada de 1 es 1 y la raíz de 4 es 2
un medio que es claramente un número
racional pues se puede escribir como una
fracción así es que este número es
racional hagamos inciso g
inciso g que es la raíz cuadrada de
nueve cuartos
la raíz cuadrada de nueve cuartos mismo
razonamiento esto se puede escribir como
la raíz cuadra de nueve sobre el raíz
cuadrada de 4 649 estrés y raíz quade 4
es 23 medios
hagamos ahora inciso h inciso h que es
la raíz cuadrada de 0.16 aquí quizás por
inspección podrías darte cuenta que la
raíz cuadrada de 16 6.44 al cuadrado es
punto 16 sin embargo te va a un
procedimiento sistemático para resolver
esto raíz cuadrada de punto 16 esto lo
puede escribir como la raíz cuadrada de
16 sobre 116 son 16 centésimas y esto
podemos describirlo como la raíz
cuadrada de 16 sobre la raíz cuadrada de
100 esto es igual a raíz cuadrada 16 64
raíz cuadrada de 100 es igual a 10 4
decimos 0.4 hagamos otro par de ejemplos
como este tenemos el inciso iii
y si soy en la raíz cuadrada de punto 1
le escribimos punto 1 como un décimo y
esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 1
sobre la raíz cuadrada de 10
la escuadra de 1 es igual a 1 con raíz
cuadrada de 10 no podemos hacer nada
porque se factorizar como 2 por 5 sería
raíz cuadrados por la escuadra de 5
vamos a dejar lo mejor como raíz
cuadrada de 10 a muchos maestros de
matemáticas no les gusta dejar la raíz
en el denominador pero lo que sí te
puedo decir es que este es un número
irracional irracional si lo pones en tu
calculadora solo vas a obtener una
aproximación pues un número irracional
tiene una expansión decimal con un
número infinito de dígitos pero si
quisieras racionalizar este número
deshacerte el radical en el denominador
lo necesitamos multiplicar por raíz
cuadrada de 10 entre raíz cuadrada de 10
lo estamos multiplicando por 1 en el
numerador tenemos raíz cuadrada de 10 y
en el denominador tenemos raíz cuadrada
de 10 por raíz cuadrada de 10 es igual a
10 verificamos que al ser la división
entre un número racional y un número
racional estamos obteniendo un número y
ración
hagamos ahora el inciso j inciso j la
raíz cuadrada de 0.01 esto lo puedo
escribir como la raíz cuadrada de 1
sobre 100 esto es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 1 sobre la raíz cuadrada de
100 esto es igual a 1 sobre 10 o lo que
lo mismo 0.1 este es un número racional
se puede escribir como una fracción así
como este número que obtuvimos acá
arriba que también se puede escribir
como una fracción es un número racional